gente esperando a ser examinada en un
centro de detección en nueva delhi
mientras la india sigue registrando
altas cifras de fallecimientos y casos
de contagio más de 145 mil personas han
muerto desde el inicio de la pandemia no
obstante los médicos dicen que el virus
circula más lento de lo esperado
en noviembre habían algunas áreas que
aumentaron en casos como de libras
gastan y kerala pero ahora hemos llegado
a un escenario en el que hay una
tendencia a la baja en contagio en
amorós quizás esto a pesar de la
anecdótica evidencia de que muchas
personas han dejado de usar el tapabocas
y de respetar la distancia de seguridad
ellos no tienen miedo de la enfermedad
por eso se está extendiendo tanto no
usan tapabocas y esa es la razón no se
desinfectan bien si tengo miedo del
virus pero también tomó precauciones el
país está planeando una campaña de
vacunación masiva en los próximos meses
el gobierno ha identificado a 300
millones de personas que se vacunarán
primero incluyendo a la población de
riesgo los trabajadores sanitarios y las
fuerzas de seguridad como centro mundial
de fabricación de vacunas la india puede
producirlas rápidamente y a bajo costo
pero los críticos dicen que los
ambiciosos planes del gobierno serán
difíciles de implementar con una
población de 1.300 millones una
infraestructura pobre y un sistema
sanitario débil